well hello reject nation it's Greg Alva
here I'm John and I'm a Charaka a chore
occurred here from Jabby TV YouTube
channel is here with us today she's
gonna help us do the reaction for the
latest black panther trailer which just
dropped I can't wait to see this guys
before we go into that I want to give a
shout out today's video sponsor and that
is the Stardust app we've been posting a
lot in the Stardust app Achara and jabby
are actually on the Stardust app as well
right now and if you guys haven't heard
of it it's an app that allows you to do
30-second reactions or reviews for any
film TV show or trailer and we're
covering a lot of TV a lot of movies
right now and there's a lot of your
favorite youtubers on it like we said a
charge a br on there
Tyrone Magnus is on there the flick pics
on there Jeremy Jones is on there Wendy
Lee a whole bunch of people we're trying
to get to 4000 followers as soon as
possible they're catching up way too
fast so download the app follow us first
there's a link in the description box
follow us first second first and then
follow them they have to know who's
Sencha and patron today shots a day for
Adelia chamberlain let's watch this
shiznit people do it
[Music]
lawman
[Music]
Oh Forest Whitaker
[Music]
[Music]
since
[Music]
[Music]
it can't you Lamar like Vince staples on
the truck yeah I asked you I said again
[Music]
maybe I'll finally get respect right
[Music]
yeah I'm actually getting a lot from
this trailer too much no no wrong
okay all right when I was feeling from
it
when I was watching it is it seems like
we're getting teases of that kind of
Marvel humor that we know of I feel like
most of the time these Black Panther
trailer so for the most part been a
little bit more on the serious side it
still got there upbeat music in there it
doesn't feel like oh the Marvel humor
that we all know and not that I think
this film is gonna be filled with that
but you get teasers of that and wrote
the script teases that within the
personality of the characters themselves
because like when he's interacting with
his own people or even just a few
throwaway lines here and there this has
this trail that has more of a sense of
fun Kendrick Lamar music backing it up
it sounds a little bit cooler I feel
like it fits with the trailer pretty
well actually well it feels like it's
closer to time you know and he's been
curating the soundtrack so it feels like
everything that this movie is is coming
together and we're about to see it I'm
so excited about like this is the most
excited I've been for this trailer
because it's also the most expansive
trailer yeah yeah like you see a good
amount of Wakanda you see a good amount
of the action that will get later on in
the movie and you get to see all the
different facets I feel like like
there's so many different locations and
different designs in this trailer like
I'm really excited to see the world
especially with condos yeah and even
though it's a TV spot and feel sure it's
obviously shorter than the other
trailers I felt like I got a better
sense of kill monger and claw yeah I
think you get more of a story like you
you feel like okay I know what's kind of
going on in or there's gonna be like
some sort of coup situation yeah which I
didn't really get from the previous
trailers that I saw yeah well they're
they're kind of focusing a little bit
more on on kill mongers the special is
like what he's capable of it this at
least a little bit I feel like they show
probably the same amount of stuff a
regular to other would but they just
don't linger on it as long well it seems
to be pretty tight on the fact that
there's kill monger and claw working
together and they're after T'Challa as
well and if this fake war is coming
right now
and two challahs connection with the
Panther God yeah
I'm really excited to see those scenes
too cuz like the colors like we only get
like a brief moment but even you pointed
out the first time we watched it like
he's talking like he's we have with him
so cool and we got to see a taste of
Zuri
Forest Whitaker's character in there - I
didn't even quite realize he was in this
until earlier this afternoon yeah I
don't know much about Missouri
characters like that spiritual type of
religious sort of character in there all
right
but of course we're showing up for the
small kind of roles tends to work out
pretty well yeah yeah yeah this is cool
trailer I can't wait man we got to get
our tickets dude can we borrow $20 from
you guys cuz we only got yellow dollar
bill signs all over our thing yeah we
gotta see some flakes coming up in the
first quarter of the year first part of
the year hasn't Pacey afforded this
video wraps up though we got to give a
shout to a Delia Chamberlin Delia Delia
is very excited for this Black Panther
movie Anna Delia right now it has she's
gone through some foot surgery and she's
in recovery mode and the meantime she's
been doing some audio logs and you know
I think she's a beautiful woman who
deserves to put her face out there right
now she's just putting her voice up
there it would put your face out there
Delia is you're one of our favorite
people over at patreon rightfully so you
two earned it a whole lot of a
conversation and insight your beautiful
woman I don't know you but I think you
sound fantastic sure I have never lost a
fight to a woman on camera but I'm
willing to write now subscribe to the
reel rejects hey click that notification
well guys follow Chara on the Jabby TV
channel it's a great reaction channel
also download and follow us on the
Stardust app people yeah having a great
time over there and hey stay sexy this
January cuz it's getting cold outside
hey I have a shot before this video nope
no you yeah you did